[Music]
what's your favorite movie of all time
that's difficult that's too hard too
hard you justice that's a difficult one
why do you have to pick that question
that's a very tough question
hmm oh they're plenty let's say Lord of
the Rings
I'll go with the stock answer in the
mood for love why won't I write it
depends if I go off like more historical
or I just picked on and stuff I mean I
think I think probably if I had to pick
one since it's probably a historical
favorite as well Pro is a Citizen Kane I
feel like it's a very good reference
representation of journalism from years
past I'm sure it's in English but in
Russian your corsage for the few recent
years I mean one I can remember of what
we brush but I mean I think it's a
decent choice even if I don't I have
limited you know I examples to come to
compare
mmm maybe from the recent movies it
would like it to name arrival I would
say maybe memento
maybe gladiators up there maybe Pulp
Fiction but it's a tough choice but
probably
a Soviet movie mimimi not
terminator I should watch more movies
[Music]